What if the computer was a beautiful object,...
...something you wanna look at and have in your home?
And what if, instead of it being in the right hands,...
...it was in everyone's hands?
We'd be talking about the most tectonic shift in the status quo since...
Ever.
We will know soon enough if you are Leonardo da Vinci or just think you are.
You're the only one who sees the world same way I do.
No one sees the world the same way you do.
You're issuing contradictory instructions,...
...you're insubordinate, you make people miserable.
The board believes you're no longer necessary to this company.
A comeback of a superstar.
Co-founder Steven Jobs...
Steve Jobs is returning to Apple.
Two most significant events of the 20th century:...
...the Allies win the war and this.
Ladies and gentlemen, Steve Jobs.